ils ne décollèrent pas des opposants à
la réforme se sont invités lundi au
conseil municipal de trappe après avoir
demandé une suspension de séance trois
prises de parole et une revendication
principale le report à 2014 de la
semaine à 4 jours et demi pour prendre
le temps de la concertation on sait même
pas de quoi on discute puisqu'il n'y a
aucune proposition officielle il n'y a
aucun document officiel il n'y a que des
bruits de couloir ici ou là il y a eu un
comité de pilotage qui s'est prononcé
sur un rythme mais on sait pas si c'est
celui qui sera repris par la mairie il
n'y a aucune communication précise sur
ce qui va s'organiser le maire a
pourtant organisé des consultations
publiques depuis le mois de février
ouvert à tous mais aujourd'hui le
dialogue semble véritablement en panne
étonné souvent interrogé parfois et et
et pas d'accord la plupart du temps et à
la sortie du conseil municipal c'est
toujours la même
incompréhension il y a pas d'information
franchement les parents ils sont pas
prés en compte il pr il est dans son
dans sa bulle il veut pas écouter les
parents sur la table la question du
début des cours qui passerait de 8h30 à
9h les activités artistiques et
sportives et puis l'inquiétude pour
certains quant au coût des accueils
aménagés avant et après l'école pour cet
enseignant c'est aussi l'égalité des
chances qui est remise en question car
la réforme prévoit que les collectivités
locales seront responsable des activités
périscolaires actuellement chaque enfant
chaque élève on va dire de CE2 de CM2
sur toute la France que soit en montagne
dans les Alpes au bord de l'eau à
Marseille dans une grande ville a les
mêmes chances de réussite que tous les
autres avec un modèle pareil ce sera
délégué à des communes avec ce que peut
avoir une commune comme budget et
l'école n'est plus égalitaire ce n'est
plus l'éducation nationale c'est
l'éducation des territoires la décision
est pourtant prise la première partie de
la réforme doit prendre effet à la
rentrée 2013 une chose est sûre la
question est loin de faire l'unanimité
au sein même de certaines associations
les désaccords déjà amené plusieurs
parents d'élèves élus à démissionner
voire à créer des branches
dissidentes